good morning welcome to the uh criminal
justice non-gain hearing of House Bill
38 um if you would please rise and join
me for the national
anthem
excuse me I won't be singing The
Pledge IED to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all I didn't mean to disappoint
everybody I'm not
singing so um if you would all just um
I'm sorry you all sit but if I would if
you wouldn't mind could everyone please
rise and join join me in a moment of
silence to remember staff sergeant
Tanner grown who was killed on November
10th he's from gor New Hampshire he was
killed in the US Army helicopter
crash thank you
H and with that I would invite County
attorney Enders to come up and tell us
about um his request
uh good morning members of the committee
my name is Steven andris I'm a
prosecutor at the Marat County
Attorney's Office I've been a prosecutor
for a little over 20
years we're talking about the habitual
offender Statute in this case it's RSA
26223 there's a sentence within that
that statute that begins with the words
provided however normally a sentence
that begins with provided however is an
exception to a
rule uh in this case you'll see that the
exception is that a sentence may be
suspended um when driving a motor
vehicle was necessitated by situations
of extreme
emergency however it's an exception to a
rule that no longer exists there used to
be a rule in 2016 in the habitual
offender statute that created a minimum
mandatory one-year sentence and there
was language in the statute that
indicated uh no portion of that minimum
mandatory shall be suspended this
created an exception to that rule the
difficulty is that in 2016 the
legislature amended the habitual
offender statute got rid of the minimum
mandatory got rid of the prohibition on
uh suspending any portion of the
sentence but left this sentence in the
reason that this creates some confusion
is we've had judges read this sentence
to to mean that they can only suspend
sentences in cases of extreme emergency
uh which I don't believe is the case I
believe that the legislature intended
judges to have discretion in the bital
offender statute which is consistent
with the prior uh ho amendment I did
send out a a handout that I wrote
yesterday to everybody emailed it and
had a couple extra hard copies if anyone
needed it and I'm happy to answer
questions about
it thank thank you
so we fixed it in 2016 so that the judge
had discretion to suspend a sentence if
he wanted to prior to that he could not
and people got the sentence we left this
in there when we did it so they still
think that they may have to impose a
minimum sentence is that correct correct
okay I know at least one judge that we
regularly go in front of reads this
sentence to mean that he can only
suspend the sentence in cases of extreme
emergency I see okay
any questions from the
committee yeah U go ahead uh
representative side under under what
circumstances would a judge be inclined
to suspend part of the
sentence uh so the habitual offender
statute I'm not sure how familiar you
are with it but in New Hampshire if you
commit a certain number of Motor Vehicle
offenses you can be certified as an
habitual
offender the they break that into major
and minor offenses so if you
accumulate I believe it's 12 speeding
tickets or it might be eight speeding
tickets um you can be certified as an
habitual offender if you accumulate
three operating after suspension charges
you can be certified as an habitual
offender because those are major
offenses so it's any combination of
three Majors 12 minors or a combination
of for example one major and I think
it's eight minors or two majors and four
minors you you can be certified as an
habitual
offender if you're certified as an
habitual offender you lose your license
for a period of 5 years so there's a
5year period you can't
drive um we've certainly had cases where
people for example lost their license as
habitual Defenders maybe 10 years ago
because they had three operating after
suspensions or um a dozen speeding
tickets and they just never bothered to
get their license back and you'll have a
situation where someone is um you know
we we've certainly had situations where
there's a car mechanic who's bringing a
car in a test drive and uh gets pulled
over and his we find out he's an
habitual offender gets charged with
being an habitual offender it it didn't
make sense in some of these cases to
send this person to prison for a period
of a year um one to five years which is
what the the prior minimum mandatory was
however it does make sense to perhaps
suspend a sentence hang hang it over
that person's head to inspire them to to
follow the law in the future so there's
certainly a lot of you know sort of fact
specific scenarios where we'd want to
provide an appropriate sentence which
would include a suspended period of time
uh to to help the person comply with the
law in the
future any further
questions represent sitech if I may
since we're pretty much on board with
this I think may I ask you a bit of
History it seems to me that a driving
offence shouldn't be more should how
does it get to be a felony a year in
jail for speeding tickets would seem
enough why did this get promoted to
felony
status so being certified as an habitual
offender itself didn't bring any jail
time with it so what would happen is if
you accumulated a certain number of
points on your license essentially or a
number of offenses within a 5year period
you'd be summoned to the DMV they would
have a hearing and they would certify
you as an habitual offender if you
didn't drive during that period you you
were fine it's not like you were going
to jail or anything for that if you did
Drive during that period of time that's
when the felony offense comes about is
you're violating the order of the
Department of Motor Vehicles not to
drive while you're certified as an
habitual offender
I don't know if that answers your
question or makes sense the question is
why is it promoted to a felony status
when I think a year in jail for speeding
tickets is plenty what motivated the
legis do this is a bit of History
nothing to do with this you don't my
I'll stop here I I can't say what
motivated the legislature at the time I
know that certainly one way to become an
habitual offender is to accumulate three
driving well intoxicated convictions and
it's strikes me that if a person
accumulates three driving will
intoxicated convictions and then
continues to drive after they've lost
their license for a period of 5 years
that that is a fairly serious offense
that does in fact deserve a felony
conviction but just for clarification
everyone here that is no longer the law
what is the current state of the law
with regard to driving after when you're
a habitual offender it is a felony if
the certification was based on a
misdemeanor a driving well intoxicated
or if you have a sub quent um habitual
offender conviction but it doesn't carry
a minimum mandatory correct it no longer
carries a minimum mandatory and it is
possible to be a misdemeanor in certain
circumstances for example the the 12
speeding tickets would be a misdemeanor
a vitual offender see so what we did is
we took out that minimum mandatory so
the judge had more discretion but at
least one judge seems to think he
doesn't have discretion and that's why
we're taking this out of here correct
yes and this sentence is just confusing
in in isolation Okay thank you any
further questions for attorney
Enders seeing none thank oh oh uh oh we
got
one just so I'm clear right now today it
has to be a save a life of lim so if we
remove all that then that means that the
judge has discretion to do whatever he
chooses to do is that correct is that
another way of looking at it sort of and
the reason I say sort of is because many
judges view this as they're able to
suspend the sentence under any
circumstances there's at least one judge
who says I can only suspend it under the
circumstances listed in the statute to
save life or limb we're trying to
clarify that judges can suspend the
sentence under any
circumstances if that makes sense okay
so yes it clarifies that they can use
their discretion to do as they please
yes it clarifies that the judges are
able to use their discretion thank which
was what the legislature intended in
2016 by removing the minimum mandatory
yes correct you're shut
off any any further questions for turn
okay see none thank you very much for
presenting us with us today and um we'll
take it up as soon as we get um clean up
on aisle
4 um there being no further Witnesses
um I hereby close the public hearing on
House Bill
38 and I open the executive session on
38 and I will make a motion of
OTP a no actually I have to introduce
the amendment I will introduce the
amendment
number 24 2 38 oh is it 11 oh I I
thought she you just scheduled it for
right afterwards oh I did okay
so pay no attention to what I just did
we will open that at 11
o00 why did she do that I told
her
okay at this point I'm opening the
executive
session on House Bill
39 and excuse excuse me 38 and I am
recognizing
myself
[Music]
to introduce amendment number 2423 H and
can I get a second seconded by
representative gaite I'll speak to the
motion the amendment is the amendment
suggested by the County Attorney we just
heard from it makes a technical fix to
the law that will allow judges
discretion to um suspend sentences
rather than impose them there are he
said that we had at least one judge out
there that felt he still had to
implement a mandatory sentence which was
clearly not our intent when we fixed it
in
2016 um though I was not here then it
seems to be pretty clear um any
discussion would you like to speak to
your second representative of Catherine
no I think you did a good jve anyone
else want to talk about it it seems
pretty clear no thank you representative
scitec actually nothing to do with this
but we're going to have an echo of this
because if you call I did not want to
gum up the
works but there is uh in one of the
bills that we let go through it said if
a bail commissioner is a a police
officer which is not permitted by other
sections of the law so one day we're
going to have to come and line that out
also but that was today wasn't the this
wasn't the day it's does no harm but I
just wanted since I had to sit here till
11 o'clock I wanted to say it yeah I I
think you're right and often as we touch
these bills it's incumbent upon us to
take a look at them and make sure
there's nothing else hanging around out
there that doesn't belong and this is uh
clearly one of those cases anyone else
seeing no one I would ask the clerk to
call the role the vote is on accepting
the amendment to the
bill representative
bogert yes representative Pratt yes
representative scitec representative PR
yes representative Kennedy yes
representative Manion yes representative
kcom yes representative Stone yes
representative tenar yes representative
Gite yes representative
Muse yes representative
manuti yes representative Vale yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
selig yes representative wheeler
chairman Roy chair votes yes
20 the uh motion carries the amendment
is adopted at this time I'll recognize
myself to make a motion to of
otpa with um House Bill 38 second
seconded by represented
appr um I don't think we need any
further discussion not seeing none I
would ask the cour to call the role the
motion on the floor is
otpa representative Stone yes
representative
Bogart yes representative Pratt yes
representative scitec yes representative
PR yes representative Kennedy yes
representative Manion yes representative
kcom yes representative tenar yes
representative Gite yes representative
Muse yes representative mapy yes
representative Vale yes representative
Murphy yes representative Newman yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative
selig representative wheeler yay
chairman
Roy chair votes yes
20 motion carries any objection to uh
consent seeing none it will go on
consent and with that I close the
executive session on House Bill
38 um and we are done for the day please
everyone I sent an email and I'm going
to remind you again if you have a report
due um I sent a uh a copy of the Green
Sheet around so you know if you have one
I need it today remember the deadline is
Friday um and I need to have time to
look at these and submit them so I need
it today tomorrow's the deadline so I
have to send them moment to the clerk
thank
you actually um one more thing um I'm
not going to see you anymore so I want
to wish you all a Happy Thanksgiving a
Merry Christmas and a happy New Year
it's been a great year working with all
of you and I look forward to seeing you
all in January to pick up our work
again